[Music]
what Oh something today falling skies
she's extremely popular it's very well
if this is your second show with Steven
Spielberg is that right he was one of
the executive producers of ER did you
have like back in the ER days when young
yeah you know just starting out you're
just getting started in business you get
ER and Steven Spielberg is one of the
guys who's an executive using it did you
have direct contact with him because
that must have been intimidating we met
early on in the process he'd show up for
big events hundredth episode you know he
get us Christmas presents but his
involvement was sort of tangental on
that show right right so so did you you
didn't get to the point where you could
like I don't know actually he had done a
movie called always about a year before
he are launched and we'd seen that he'd
bought the cast of always these Mazda
Miata cars as a wrap gift as a gift to
see if everyone in the movie a Mazda
Miata yeah Wow for Christmas you got us
all these little cell phones so mr.
Clooney thought it would be very funny
if we all wrote thank-you notes saying
dear Steven thank you for the Miata cell
phone and he said we should do this
he'll think it's funny and I go you're
gonna do it you goes oh I'm gonna do it
and so I wrote that letter and as the
last Christmas present I ever got
here's the important thing did George
Clooney write it as well I don't believe
he did DreamWorks movie the very next
year yeah he screwed you over he got you
to do it you know live and learn
live and learn no I would have learned
right away
hey now is he involved he's involved
all over this show yeah all over the
show yeah he's and we only benefit from
his involvement he weighs in on the
scripts and he weighs in on casting and
he watches all the episodes he watches
all the dailies he is really hands-on in
post-production in designing all the
spaceships and aliens he this is one of
his favorite shows that he produces and
and he's all over it does he ever like
come in and say I've got an idea this
you know you know this I had this dream
do this episode and his ideas are great
actually it's funny because the only
idea he ever had for ER he'd worked in a
hospital emergency room when he was in
high school and he told the writers the
story about how a dog was brought in
once and the doctors gave it
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation and so the
very next week this German Shepherd is
brought in on the aviary I had this
sucker and this dogs so now to give it
mouth to message you had to do it oh
that's a wonderful idea that he brought
in yeah science fiction is his is his
wheelhouse though you I was talking to
you backstage you have two beautiful
kids you brought him and I was chatting
with them it's funny I've been on your
show a million times I've never been
more nervous than I am right now because
both of my kids are backstage watching
me going that wasn't funny that was and
that's that's kids too that's I mean
that's all of our kids my kids no matter
I come in in the morning on my car yeah
kids they yeah okay you're gonna
yeah well they don't do that Jimmy
my son does not interested dad you ain't
got it today alright so I'm in kids they
know what you do and they've seen that
you've had a lot of success do you think
they're gonna want to act or get in the
business I don't know sometimes they
show interest my son has a very kind of
strong directorial vision he comes to
visit every once in a while on the set
and I remember we shot a scene once
where I had to beat an alien over the
head with a shotgun in a steam tunnel
and my son was sitting in the chair
watching on the monitor and I came over
after the take and I said out of breath
you know would you think and he goes uh
it was good on the last tick you hit him
seven times on this one you hit him six
six works better than the seven but on
the last hit you're holding the gun up
too high and it's not staying in the
frame so hold it over your left shoulder
you'll stay in the picture okay good we
got it It's A Wrap
let's go nice dead let's go